All right. Good afternoon, Sunset Valley
families, staff members,
and community members. My name is Elena
Varo. I'm your very, very proud
principal, and I just want to
thank you. I just want to thank everyone
um from the bottom of my heart for
taking time out of your busy day to
attend this community meeting to just
get more informed, feel um like you had
an opportunity to voice opinion, ask a
question. I'm very thankful for Matia
Seura, our amazing superintendent, and
his leadership team um for scheduling
this and their agendas and creating this
opportunity for all of us. So, I'm going
to transition um the microphone to
Christina Gwyn, who will um go over our
norms and some logistical things for our
meeting.
Okay. Hi everyone. Um, thank you so much
for being here. I'm just going to kick
off the meeting with a little
housekeeping. So, if everyone uh or
anyone needs to go to the restroom, I'm
sure many of y'all know where to go
because this is your school, but if you
don't, it's right out um this door and
around the right corner. Um, so we'll
have our agenda. We just did the
principal welcome. Um, I'll go through
some of the meeting norms, some
introductions, and then we'll get right
to it with a little bit of an overview
of um, what we're here to discuss. And
then we have pulled some of the comment
card information.
And we'll go through some of the comment
card uh, questions and answers, and then
we'll open it up for a larger
discussion. And I do want to just start
off, I know um, Matias may say it too,
but just thank you to this community.
y'all have been so communicative and uh
so open with us and we really appreciate
it and I think it's going to set us up
for a really strong conversation today.
So with these are the meeting norms and
I won't read every single thing but I'll
um kind of read through the um bold. So
we are building the future together. Um
this is a really hard conversation.
These are really hard uh spaces to be in
and I think even acknowledging just that
that we are all working together is
really important. Um honoring time. So
we're trying to keep it to at least a
minute. We have about an hour and a half
here. Um and so if we can just make sure
to um think through how making sure how
we can get as many people um on the mic
or get their questions answered as
possible, that would be great. Um honor
each other. um honor process, honor
intent and impact, honor space and voice
and stay solutionoriented
and then embrace transparency and
empathy. Again, really difficult
conversations and I think if we can just
come to it um with that empathy, it's
going to be really important
to finish.
Um so again with the meeting purpose, we
are here to answer questions and talk
about those future solutions. So, we
will be going through some of the
comment card um submissions. There were
quite a few and so our team has really
gone through and pulled some some have
multiple um people that have submitted
them and so we've kind of looped them
into one question. Um and then we just
want to again get a shared understanding
of the rationale and then gain some
insights as we move forward towards that
next deliverable um that'll be coming
out next week and then also uh as we
work towards that final proposal next
month.
And so with that, I'm going to hand it
straight over to our superintendent
here. Use this one.
>> I don't know how to turn that one on.
>> Oh, it is. Okay. you can.
>> Well, um, so first off, I just want to
say thank you, uh, for being here this
afternoon. Um, and also want to
acknowledge just how difficult this
conversation is. Uh, you know, I'm I am
someone who deeply deeply loves our
schools. Um, and many of y'all may not
know, but I'm from South Austin. I grew
up just down the road. My kids went to
Sunset Valley. Um, I had my first parent
teacher conference here in this
building. Um, I walked the halls all the
way through and I I just want you to
know like um this is hard. It's hard for
lots of individuals in our community and
also within our staff. Uh I'm hopeful
that you know we can have a conversation
and we can talk about you know all the
things. But I want you to know like I am
committed to doing this the right way no
matter how difficult it is. And what
we're attempting to do is to evolve as a
school system and get to a place where
our precious resources, and they are
precious, um are allocated to our
students and to our school communities
that need them most and at the same time
provide academic experiences for all of
our students across the city of Austin.
And when we talk about what that looks
like, it's having strong neighborhood
schools. And we can define what that is.
And I want to be really honest, like we
have incredible schools everywhere, but
not every student is getting what they
need to be academically successful. And
that's not a the fault of this
administration or this board. It is a
compounding effect of 144 years of
decisions that were made before this
moment.
And so when we talked about what this
looks like, we talked about a plan that
was going to address multiple things.
And this plan does that. Um, and it's
not a perfect plan. There's no such
thing. But we wanted to align feeder
patterns. There are parts of Austin, you
know, some in West Northwest Austin that
have clear feeders where the entire
middle school goes to the high school.
You see that at Merkasen and Anderson.
You see it at O'Henry and Austin High.
You see it at Kuritzky and Buoie. Where
do you not see it? You don't see it in
East Austin. You have middle schools
that go to four and five high schools.
Communities get broken up. PTAs can't
stay together. It's incredibly
disruptive and we have never as a school
system taken that on. This plan
addresses that. We also have to
acknowledge that there is a strain in
our stability from a financial
perspective. You know that we've been
running a deficit budget and we'll have
conversations around well Matias like
what did you do like two years ago or
five years ago? I want you to know that
we the board and myself have been very
intentional about paying for the things
that align with our values. and shedding
the things that we know we could and
still protect our schools. And we did
that for the last two years. And we're
at a point now with the disruptions at
the federal level, the compress the
pressure we have from the state, we
simply cannot continue without
introducing real risk into our system,
financial risk. And I want to be really,
really clear. One of the things that
causes the Texas Education Agency to act
in many cases is not accountability.
It's financial solveny. right? The first
rating and we can talk about that. And
so this plan attempts right to reduce
the number of empty seats we have in our
school system and that includes
boundaries and consolidations.
It also attempts to not overburden any
one specific part of Austin. you know,
over last, I would say 20 years, there's
a real argument to be made that the East
Austin and Eastern Crescent really kind
of took the majority of the burden when
it came to any systematic improvement.
And so because we're also looking at
programmatic moves, in this case,
wall-to-wall dual language, we're able
to position programs to be successful
for years to come, create um access for
those students, emerging bilingual
students specifically, who haven't had
it, and ultimately do two things, right?
Position the schools programmatically to
be successful and not overburden anyone
side of the city. uh when it comes to
consolidations. The other thing that it
does is we are in a real real struggle
right now to address accountability. So
you all know that 23 24 and 25
accountability ratings came out within
three or within five months of each
other, right? And yes, there's been
disruptions in the systems and yes,
we've moved the system. You know, we
three three or four years ago, we had,
you know, 70% teacher retention rate.
Now we're at 88%. When I first came on
board, we hired 24 principles. Now we're
hiring between five and six a year. The
system has really responded and we're
seeing outcomes move. But unless we
address these turnaround plans, and we
can talk about what those are as we move
forward, we
risk our ability to maintain local
control. And I tell when I tell you
this, it is really important for me as a
leader of this organization to ensure
that our trustees, the people that you
elected, have the ability to continue to
determine how we educate our 70,000
students here in Austin ISD. And if you
look around the state, it is a real
risk. It's not something I am um willing
to to kind of diminish. I'm honest about
it. We're going to own it and we're
going to take it on and we're going to
ultimately be successful. But I want you
to know that this plan considers that
movement as well. The last thing I'll
say is there have been challenges within
our tr uh transfer policies and they're
just messy, y'all. Uh we have transfer
policies that have we've had to, you
know, really kind of retire because they
weren't compliant legally. We have some
that were made, you know, in years past
that have drawn students from East
Austin to different parts of Austin. we
have um transfer policies and procedures
that have overenrolled some schools that
should never been overenrolled, right?
And so we really have to take a good
look at that and this plan considers
that as well. I want you to know that um
all of this is coming together in a very
multiaceted
complex plan. But I will say that if you
took any one of these things in
isolation, it would not look the same.
It just wouldn't. And we can talk about
what that would look like. Um, I'll
cover this slide and then I'll have
Christine um talk about uh kind of more
details, but for um Sunset Valley
Elementary School, as you all know, the
plan um includes the movement of the
wall-to-wall dual language program to
ODM Elementary School uh within the
zip code. Um I know that community very
very well. uh and it attempts to move
the um access um from where it currently
is for emerging bilingual students to a
place where we have a higher population.
We know where they live, right? Right.
And we also know that it is um
historically been uh challenging for
those families to get access to these
schools. And when you think about where
for wall-to-wall dual language
wallto-all language programs are and
their current emerging bilingual student
populations, they are moving in the
wrong direction and they're they're low.
And so um this this plan will ultimately
add more seats. And because we have to
assign students who are currently
assigned to Sunset Valley, we are
reassigning those students to both Boone
and to Cunningham, both incredible
neighborhood schools. Um, and I I just
want you to know that we don't look at
anyone school in isolation. I know
there'll be questions about Jocelyn,
there'll be questions around Boone and
Cowan and others. We look at the region
as a whole and understand that we have
to think about how any one of these
moves impacts the others. We'll share
with you our logic and our approach. And
again, it's not perfect. We are able to
refine and make adjustments. Um, but I I
wanted you to to kind of know the
thought process for how we got here. Uh,
and the driving factors um that we
wanted to make sure were considered as
part of this plan. So, Christine, you
want to kind take us to the next?
>> Yeah. Thank you, Superintendent Sigura.
Hi, everyone. My name is Christine
Steampport. I'm the operations officer
for Austin ISD. So, I'm just going to
take you through a few slides which you
probably already know, but I wanted to
kind of get us on the same page here.
And I know that we want to have a lot of
Q&A today. So, I'll kind of go through
these quickly so we can get to that. So,
um, as we know as a part of this
proposal, what would this mean for my
school, Sunset Valley? Um, the building
would be closed, proposed to be closed,
and the neighborhood students would be
reassigned to Cunningham and Boone
Elementary. And that's if you are living
in these new boundaries. and we'll get
to what that looks like. I know
Superintendent Sigura just spoke a
little bit about the schoolwide dual
language program and how that would be
moving and how we're going to have
district-wide um choice programs. So,
that's something different for Austin
ISD and we'll get into that a little bit
more as well. But so that this technical
pro this technical school program would
be reassigned essentially to ODM
Elementary. Next slide.
So, if you live in the Sunset Valley uh
elementary current zone, like I said
before, you can apply you can um either
choose to go to your zone school or you
can apply for a priority seat at the um
schoolwide dual language program at ODM.
Uh if you're a transfer, you can
continue, you can return to your zone
school or apply for a priority seat at
the schoolwide dual language program at
ODM. and we have made it very very um
clear that we want we have enough seats
not only for the emergent bilingual
students living in the ODM zone but also
the program students here at Sunset
Valley. So just wanted to be really
clear with that as well. Um next slide
when I'll bring us to the boundaries and
so this is just showcasing some of the
collateral documents that we had in the
proposal and that proposed package as
you'll see on the left this was the
Sunset Valley boundary as it currently
is. And then on the right, this would be
the reassignments if you will. So the
green here is now the reassignment. If
you live in this area, you would be
reassigned zone to Cunningham. And then
in the pink area, the hatched. If you
live in this zone, you would be
reassigned to Boone. And so those are
kind of some of what that looks like
there. Um, next slide. So we're let's
get to the meat and bones of it. I'm
going to pass it to Christina and she's
going to start us off on our Q&A. And so
we're going to start with some comment
cards and some larger themes of what
we've heard from you all. And I want to
echo her sentiments, too. It has been an
amazing feedback and organization that
you all have had, and we appreciate the
thoughtfulness and the thoroughess of
your communication. So, I just wanted to
say that, echo that as well.
>> Okay. And before we get into it, I'm
going to put some of our trustees on the
spot to welcome them and thank them for
coming. So, we have our uh board
secretary, Andrew Gonzalez, and then our
um district 7 trustee, Dr. Kaufman. So,
thank you for being here.
[Applause]
Okay, so we're going to get into the
comment cards. Um first question, will
all of Sunset Valley fit at ODM if
current students stay for DL programming
and other schools like Becker families
also choose ODM over Sanchez? So,
>> thank you so much. Thank you for being
here and it's nice to see some familiar
faces from the last meeting where we
were here. So my name is Evette Gardinas
and I have the honor of supporting
campuses with multilingual education and
early learning. So to answer this
question and we heard uh Miss Steampport
say that we do have enough seats at ODM
for if we just basically took all of the
students that are participating in dual
language at ODM elementary and took all
of the students that are participating
in dual language here in Sunset Valley.
We would have enough seats for for both
campuses.
Um the other question um is about like
schools like Becker. So, I do want to
say also that we have a commitment to uh
really prioritize, right, the families
from Sunset Valley to be able to go into
ODM. So, just wanted to make sure.
>> Yeah. And just to put a finer point on
it, we made a commitment to um uh reduce
wherever we could any disruption and I
certainly recognize and our trustees
have committed to me clearly that
anytime that you break up a community uh
that's a disruption and so that is not
our goal. That's not our intent. Um, we
know that this plan includes a move and
so our objective would be to as holy as
possible those who chose to continue
together all gu be guaranteed a spot at
ODM. Uh, but I also want to acknowledge
as based on the comment that there's
questions from other wall-to-wall
deluage programs. If that was the case,
uh you all or the those who are here at
Sensit Valley would be approved
automatically and then they would be a a
priority um kind of below if that makes
any sense because we want to make sure
we provide the space here. Now for the
Becker transition to S Sanchez
Elementary School, the inverse would be
true, right? where they would have
perhaps the guaranteed transfer and then
if a Sunset Valley student or family
wanted to go to Sanchez, they would be
prioritized just right behind them, but
that would be way above all the other
transfers that we would be considering.
So, we are wanting to be very
intentional. We making adjustments. I
know some of the language in here is a
little softer than you probably want to
hear, and that's because we're really
intentional about version control. We've
already been able to make adjustments on
transfer language, committing to um uh
different things that weren't in the
original plan. We just I can say that
verbally that we're getting very close.
I just can't say yet that it's um it's
in the plan, but I can promise you that
it's very very close and that's the
direction that we intend to go.
>> Okay. Most of our emergent bilingual
families are zoned and walk to our
campus. Will they be given the
transportation to ODM to ensure they can
take advantage of this opportunity to
move with the community? Sunset Valley
is more than two miles from ODM, though
not each family may be two miles away.
This is a high equity priority for our
campus and a way to ensure the community
and strength of the program remains.
Thank you, Christina. Um, in our
original version, we did not have that
included, but that is something that, as
Superintendent Sakura is alluding to,
we're hearing very loud and clear that
that's very important to families. And
so, that's some considerations that
we're doing, not only just with Sunset
Valley, but with other schools as well
and looking at, okay, uh, if that can be
done right, what are the cost things
associated with that? So, that's
something that we're still looking at.
Um, but we've heard loud and clear that
that's very important to many of those
communities.
>> Yeah. And so just to I don't want to
just to be really precise about this
with the four elementary schools that
are receiving Walto language programs
you know Wooten Pickle Sanchez and ODM
one of the things that we are very close
to being able to incorporate is
committing to having transportation with
within that area to ensure that our
emerging bilingual students have access.
Right. So being close is helpful, but
until they have transportation, it may
not be um at a point where we know
they'll take advantage of it. Uh and
because we're moving towards a
district-wide
um solution, uh that typically wouldn't
be provided, but that is an adjustment
that we um are heavily considering and I
think we'll be able to get there. This
question seems to me as though if
there's an emerging bilingual student
who is outside of the receiving
attendance boundary and perhaps not even
living within Sunset Valley attendance
boundary, what that would look like. And
in that case, it would be very nuanced.
Um I can't say for certain that we'd be
able to provide um transportation. Um
that's not something we have currently
in policy. Um, you know, I recognize um
the challenges that may bring uh but
that specific element of that question.
Uh we don't have the ability to provide
transportation in that instance. Um you
know, just because of kind of the cost
associated with it and the fact that it
may be just one or two students. But we
would then look to see, okay, where does
that student reside? Is there a dual
language um opportunity that is closer
to that student or do one of these other
wall-to-wall dual language programs
actually offer um you know just uh
access in a different way than the ODM
would. So I it is top of mind uh and why
will we go through the process the
transitional matter we'll make those
adjustments and move forward.
>> Because ODM will be nonzoneed will all
graduates then metriculate to their
different middle schools or is the
district planning a dual language feeder
pattern as well? How soon will we know
what the plan is for that feeder? This
will help ease famil family's concerns.
>> Yeah, thank you so much. That's a great
question that's been coming up. And
again, as we've said, we are reading all
the comments on the comment cards, um
all the feedback that's coming in. So,
we are looking at feeders, right? We've
heard Superintendent Sagura talk about
feeders for other campuses, specifically
for our um own zone campuses. We're also
looking to establish feeders. So that
that is something that we're currently
um mapping out and um and so again I'll
just share with you we are also looking
at kind of natural feeders right of
where a school would go to um but those
are still pieces of conversation that
we're having. We understand again it's
important for continuation of program
right so that is something that we are
considering as we're having these
conversations.
>> Okay. Thank you. Okay. Now, I am
extremely worried about my other
daughter who received special education,
speech therapies, and thanks to the
teachers and therapists who have helped
us with the whole process, my daughter
has received help since she was 2 years
old. She has started school at three and
that is a huge advantage that she has
had. How can we be sure that this sense
of community and support will not be
affected?
>> So, I'm going to introduce Dr. Cherry
Lee um who is our assistant
superintendent of special education.
She's been the person who's been leading
all of our work in the response to TA
agreed order and really stabilizing our
system. I do want to point out um that
the allocation of staff is not something
when it comes to uh you know those
individuals who are certified whether
it's diagnosticians or um you know
teachers that are uh certified those are
in her purview not in the talent and
strategy purview because sometimes we
there are questions around you know will
the plan doesn't include uh special
education staff transitioning and that
is because we place staff based on
student need and that is a different
process that is within her purview
placement of staff that support students
who receive special education services
not in the same purview as Brandy Hosk
who's our um talent strategy officer who
oversees the all the other um placement
of staff. So that's one of the I think
little clarifications I want to make
before you took over the floor.
>> Thank you. Thank you for being here uh
this afternoon. And so to this question,
all speech therapy, occupational
therapy, physical therapy, dyslexia
intervention, behavior supports,
personal care services, which it could
include nursing will continue with the
child. The child's IEP or their
individualized education program will
guide all the services and supports that
that student receives. So for students
receiving special education that are at
a that is at a campus that is going to
be consolidated once the plan is
approved, we will be holding ARD
meetings which are the meetings where we
determine those specialized services for
students with families in the spring so
we can make any adjustments as needed.
And those services will follow the child
to the students newly zoned campus. For
families that are opting to stay with
the dual language program or a language
immer im immersion program, we will
determine if those services can be
provided at that campus. There's a few
specialized services that include early
childhood special education and life
skill service programs that are not
offered at every single elementary
school. Right? Life skills in a full
continuum of services is offered at
every single middle school and high
school. But life skills and early
childhood special education services are
not offered at every single one of our
elementary schools. So there may be some
unique circumstances where we are
considering a centralized placement at
another school for those specific
services. But again, speech therapy,
occupational therapy, physical therapy,
behavior intervention supports, those
services are provided at all of Austin
ISD campuses.
>> Thank you.
What is the plan for the transition of
special education teachers? Can you say
if there are not included in the
flowcharts of the plans presented? And I
think that's what Yeah.
>> Yeah.
So, we are carefully looking at all of
those uh staffing allocations right now
and at this time there is no plan to
reduce the number of positions uh for
special education uh teachers or
teaching assistants or speech
pathologists and we'll be looking very
very carefully um to determine where
those persons will be serving. Many of
our providers like our speech therapists
and our occupational therapists, our
diagnosticians, our school psychologists
are serving at several campuses. Now,
they might not be serving just one
campus. So, we'll be looking very
closely at uh the campuses and
communities that where they're serving
and then where there will be, but we are
not planning in any reductions of staff
in our special education uh service team
at this time.
Okay. I don't understand why Joselyn is
being kept as an open campus instead of
Sunset. The campus building score is
much lower than Sunset. The grounds are
much smaller and it's located on a
dangerous street. The Sunset Valley
campus benefits from a large property,
ample parking nearby, and close
protection from Sunset Valley PD. Plus,
all roads are neighborhood roads. So, we
had multiple commenters with that.
>> Yeah. So, um I always get anxious when
we talk about other school without the
school around. Um, but I want you to
know, as I said before, this was a a
regional approach to um all the moves in
an effort to to
address the goals of the overall plan.
Um, again, we wanted to identify ways to
become more efficient. We have lots of
schools that are utilized. We have um
transferin rates that are very, very
high and also in an effort to stabilize
programming long term, moving programs
wall to wall to where there are more
higher numbers of emerging bilingual
students. When it when it comes to JSON,
what I'll say is uh it it really came
down to the movement of the other
schools. Anytime you move a school,
there's going to be things that occur
next to it. In this case, you have
Cuttingham and Boone, you have St. Elmo,
you have Joselyn to the north, you have
Galindo, Dawson. There's just a lot that
occurs. And you think about, you know,
we can talk about the facility, you can
talk about access. We created the rubric
to identify where we had misalignments
and then we took a regional approach. Um
the other thing I'll say is um you know
when we identified the campuses and the
programming in those campuses uh we felt
as though um Jocelyn and the um
programming that uh is supported and
it's going to shift. I want you all to
know it's going to shift uh slightly
than what it is currently. Um it's not
going to be a zoned campus. is going to
go to an unzoneed campus and be the
Mandarin kind of offering to the south
as Riley currently is to the north along
with DOSS. And so if we if we would have
thought about okay what does it look
like to kind of completely transition
you would have been really struggling to
create that access to that programming
in South Austin. And so uh what I'll say
is um it wasn't uh one or the other. It
was really, you know, the complement of
moves in order to try to move towards
our goal of of of addressing all these
things simultaneously. Um certainly
happy to spend more time talking about,
you know, different details of it or
Matias like why did you pick this street
or this street? We can have that
conversation. Um but that was the
overall approach. Um I don't know Rachel
if there's anything else you'd like to
add specifically to it.
>> Okay.
>> Okay. I mean I that's just the I mean I
I know that people want like why this or
not that there it is it is didn't come
down to a rubric. You know we I know
when the rubric came out when the rubric
came out there was a lot of
conversations around I'm I'm sorry sir
but when the rubric came out there was
conversations around is this a
consolidation list and we said no it's
not what it identifies as where we have
imbalances in the system and then we
went to work on a regional basis and
understood that every school impact
impacts another school and so this is
the solution or the plan the draft plan
we arrived at um for all the reasons I
just mentioned and and also um you know
others
Okay, moving on to the next question.
When are these proposed changes going to
start? How many students are expected to
be in each of these classrooms? And is
there a legal maximum per classroom?
>> Thank you. I'll start with that and then
I'll um pop over to my colleague um
Jennifer Pace to kind of talk about
classroom capacities. So, this is propos
this is proposed to start in August of
2026, so the beginning of next school
year. So, we are really trying to work
with a short timeline. Um, we understand
that a lot of school districts do this
right in two years and we are doing it
in a year. But I think what is most
important is that to ensure the timeline
gives families time to plan and make
decisions and make choices based off of
families and your decisions and your
life. Um, so that this would be in
August of 2026. And kind of to the two
other questions about how many students
are expected to be in each of these
classrooms, we are not changing any
student teacher ratios whatsoever. And I
wanted to just highlight that and for
the legal maximum I will defer to the
call.
>> Yeah. So it's 22 to1 studenttoteer
ratio. Um that is not what we typically
see in Austin ISD. Um because students
don't come in unique compact 22
packages. It doesn't work that way. You
might have 18, 19, and 23. It really
depends on kind of the allocations and
the principles um kind of leadership of
that campus. So it it does vary. You can
exceed that with a variance from the
Texas Education Agency. uh we we really
really try not to go down that path. Uh
we seldom do it. Um that is available to
us, but that is not part of the plan.
It's something we're considering. Uh the
last thing I'll say is um uh regarding
the 26 start of the school year. I I I
want to kind of address this because
there's been conversations around, you
know, how much time is this taking and
does it it feels rushed and it feels,
you know, there's a lot happening in a
relatively short period of time. What I
would say is that it's urgent. Um, we
started communicating on this plan in
February and March. We knew that we
would be here in November taking a vote
or at least I would be presenting a
draft plan to our trustees for
consideration. I want you to know that
what's really important for us or for
for the for for me is to make sure that
we don't take away the one thing that we
know our families need and that's time
to plan. You got to have time to plan.
And so when you think about where we are
as a system, we are already preparing
for the 2627 school year. Enrollment is
about to start. Registration is about to
start in November. So that starts in
November. It goes all the way through
March. If the delay in vote occurs in
December, then I've lost we've lost one
out of the four months that I have. And
then your frustration with the
enrollment system and process is going
to escalate. And I know how frustrating
that is. I know it hasn't been perfect,
but if we don't have the time to execute
the plan, then I'm only going to
introduce harm into our to our families
and to our students as they move into
the the next campus and then continue on
through their academic journey. So, it's
really really important for me to be
honest about what you lose or what we
lose if we delay vote or delay action.
The other thing I'll say is um I am not
going to ever ever ever
um propose or commit to a significant
change in the spring semester. We've
done that as an organization. Many of
y'all may not know this, but just a
couple years ago, we've made some pretty
significant changes. We took sixth grade
out of Mendes and Martin in in April. We
took international high school at
Eastside early college high school um in
the spring semester. We struggled
through the summer to even have a
successful launch and I would argue that
it didn't it never be was successful. Uh
so that's not something we would do. Um
so for for us this timeline um is is
appropriate. Uh if we miss the timeline
then I I would argue that you know
opportunities would be missed and risk
would be introduced. Uh and we can talk
about what those are. We can disagree or
agree, but I want to be honest about how
we're assessing timeline as all of this
works, but I want to make sure our
families have time to to to process to
plan and our staff as well. We've made
decisions on timeline. I would like to
have our principles placed at these
schools by December. I think that you
all would want to know, you know, if
this plan is going forward, who the
principal is. And so that's something
that cannot happen until the bo board
takes the vote. So, and and the reason
is is because we can't commit until that
action has taken place. I don't have the
authority to close the school or to to
change boundaries. Only the board does.
Um, which is why this sequence of timing
is important. If the principal isn't
isn't named in December and isn't named
in January, then now they're six weeks
behind hiring their staff or going
through transition planning and working
with their other community that they're
going to be working and and planning
with. So, to me, um, I just want you to
know that that is there's a lot
happening in the background. I want to
make sure we can execute at a high level
um and support all of our families
through this transition.
>> I would also like to know if the value
of the land and potential profit from
its sale or redevelopment played a role
in the decision. If so, the community
deserves to understand how those factors
were weighed. I'll
>> answer that.
>> Um especially when schools with lower
Rubik scores were not selected for
closure.
>> So the answer is no. not a not a single
point in the process did the value of
any one of these tracks of land come
into play. Like that's the honest truth.
Uh it never did. And in fact, if that
was the case, you'd probably make an
argument that these weren't the right
ones to do um when you think about it.
Uh so never part of it. Um we um have
been clear that if we are able to move
forward with a vote, we'll go through a
process and plan with community. We'll
plan with our board. uh will determine
what makes sense um for uh that
community. You've seen us now at Peas
Elementary School. That was a desire of
us in our community and our board to
actually have students still be in the
building. And we did a deal with United
Way and now it's an early childhood
center, right? We have housing in
certain parts of our of of AISD now to
support teachers that can't otherwise
afford to live in Austin. Uh we'll also
look at other solutions. So, I just want
you to know that was not part of it. it
never came into play. Uh it was not part
of the rubric, not part of anything. Um
we recognize that there will be a
process that we'll go through. There'll
be, you know, potential revenue
opportunities. We've been really clear.
We're not estimating what those are, but
we'll go through that process with
community um not um kind of separated
from uh the local community.
>> Okay.
Hold on.
Okay.
What I don't understand is reszoning
those of us who live south of William
Cannon and west of Westgate to send our
children to Boone rather than Cowan.
Living west of Westgate means the
fastest route to Boone would likely take
many families south to Davis,
approximately 500 ft from Cowan before
continuing west towards Brody Lane and
another 1.5 miles to Boone. I implore
the district to consider shifting Boone
um eastern boundary to Long View Road so
that our children may attend a school in
their neighborhood with their neighbors.
Awesome.
Um, yes, this is one of
>> Can you introduce yourself? Hi. I'm
sorry, guys. I forgot to do
introductions earlier, so I'm just going
to have all the speakers introduce
themselves before they speak.
>> No worries. Hi, I'm Rachel French. I'm
director of planning and the project
manager for our consolidations work.
>> Um, this is something we are looking at.
So, this is a great example of exactly
the kind of feedback that is so helpful
right now. And so, that is in the queue.
We are meeting with our demographers
every day. this week non-stop. Pretty
much looking through these very detailed
examples of just making sure that it's a
if it's a little change that only
affects a few blocks, easy, right? We
just have to make sure there's no what
we call feathering of like a little it
might look like a little change, but it
actually then doesn't align with maybe
the middle school or it actually creates
the school next door being too full or
too empty. And so, as long as all of
those things um are resolved and not an
issue, then we are very much making
changes. And so just thank you for that
level of detail because that is very
helpful and so if we are able to make
that change it would be reflected in the
um edited version that you'll get to see
next week.
>> Y thank you. Um okay, another one. I
strongly urge AIS to revisit boundary
lines for Barton View. It's clear that
our area has been uniquely carved out
and reassigned in a way that does not
align with our established community
connections, natural geography, and
daily travel patterns. We are also the
only neighborhood north of Highway 290
not assigned to Austin High. In
addition, Barton View appears to be the
only small neighborhood reassigned to
three entirely new schools, while most
other schools are transitioning together
with only one new campus.
Pretty much the same answer as last
time. So, thank y'all for pointing this
out. We are looking at this area um and
it is in the queue. We will probably
look at it. I mean, we will look at it
this week. Um, and so I don't have a
more definitive like yes, we can do this
because as you imagine, we have 3,000
plus comments we are looking through,
but this is absolutely something we've
heard, we are looking at, and if we
don't make the change, we will tell you
why.
Thank you. Okay. I'm curious if the
district would be open to allowing the
four schoolwide 2-way DL campuses to
form a 1882 partnership network, sharing
things like curriculum, PD, staff,
family engagement, and more. I think
it's important these schools report to
the same principal supervisor, someone
who ideally only works with these four
campuses. A partnership would also bring
in extra funding which would offset some
of the program cost and allow for that
narrow span of management. And before
you start, I'd love for you to also
clarify for everyone what an 1882 is in
your answer.
>> Uh yeah, so an 1882 partnership um was
approved by the state legislature some
some years ago. And what it allows
school districts to do is to partner
with um a diff different types of
schools. It can be a charter school uh
that's in um uh kind of good standing.
That would be, you know, like I don't
even going to name them, but it could be
like a charter school. It could be a
campus or a school system that's
directly tied to a school improvement
model. You might argue like third future
would be an 1882 partnership. The
school, the partner that's um currently
at Mendes. So 1882s um have evolved
since they came into play. uh the access
of funding and the way that they get
funded and supported by the state has
changed. So when I looked at this
question, when I read it now, um I'm not
convinced that there's actually a huge
opportunity for funding. Uh it's
actually um it's it's harder than than
maybe it seems. It's just to kind of
create a network and then create an
1882. Uh we wouldn't be able to do it
ourselves. Uh we would have to have a
partner come in and and they would be
the 1882 partner. you would do a
contract with them and that's how it
would occur. Uh I will tell you that
principal Navado uh and the other
principles one of the things that we did
by design uh was ensure that they all
were kind of out of the same um
leadership uh tree if for lack of a
better way to describe it. Um you know I
had actually had the pleasure of hiring
her. She's an incredible leader um and
has done an incredible job. So she does
actually connect very closely with the
other wall to uh four wall-to-wall
deluage programs. I think there's
opportunity on my side to strengthen um
and improve how we support these
programs as we move forward because we
are going to be adding more seats. What
I will say is adding a supervisor um you
know an executive director to four
schools uh schools that um haven't
historically uh had the same needs as
others would bring a ratio that would be
atypical. So typically if we have
schools that have um not performed and
maybe have um accountability ratings or
just other challenges a 1:6 ratio is
what we would use uh for elementary
schools just generally you know um like
a 11 to 12 to1 and then high schools uh
a little bit less and so having a 4:1
ratio for supervisory um support would
be um challenging but I will say that uh
avet um here as the um lead over
multilingual education
is kind of functions as that from the
academic side. So I don't know if it's
worth you kind of sharing your role in
organization or kind of what you'd
envision, but for the 1882 partnership
side, it's just not that simple. There
is a lot to that um to this question and
it would take some time to get there,
but I understand kind of the desire
embedded within the question.
>> Yeah. So for this, I actually also
wanted to invite Jennifer Pace. We can
tag team this one. I'm excited about
this question just to talk about the
curriculum, right, and the professional
learning that goes into this. There has
been such a shift um with our curriculum
writing. We're using high quality
instructional materials and then also
just the the partnership between
multilingual education and our
humanities and STEM team, right, for
writing very aligned curriculum that is
looking at biiteracy, that's looking
just really thinking about the dual
language student. So, um, it's been such
a great partnership and that's why I
wanted to have Jennifer Pace come up.
She's the assistant superintendent of
schools and I I can't honestly say that
years ago I could pass it on over to her
and she could talk all about curriculum
and professional learning, but she can
do that now. And I just want to mention
also before I pass the baton, just the
professional learning. So, we engage in
a lot of professional learning. um their
district days and then campusbased we
have professional learning communities
where teachers work together right at
grade levels to talk about upcoming
lessons to preview to talk about data so
there's a lot of collaboration when it
comes to the instructional pieces
>> thank you um it's great to be here this
evening and I would just add that um we
are very focused on professional
learning for our executive directors as
well who are supporting principles um
and being uh mindful of the dual
language model. They're not just in our
wall-to-wall campuses like we have dual
language in many of our campuses. So,
all of our principal supervisors are um
very familiar with the program and
continuing to learn and be um strong
supports to principles. So, regardless
of principal supervisor, we are all on
the same page thanks to this
partnership.
>> Thank you.
Okay, we have two mi two more comment
card questions and then we can open it
up. Um,
how much taxpayer money was spent
upgrading Sunset Valley Elementary over
the summer only for AISD to announce the
school is slated to close next year? How
should parents have confidence in AISD
when such poor planning results in the
waste of taxpayer dollars in a time when
the district is in such a huge deficit?
Families need to know how much bond
monies was spent this year on schools
slated for closure and how this
happened.
Thank you. And thank for thanks for that
question. I think that comes up with
many of our schools because our 2022
bond was quite amazing in the fact that
we were able to touch every Austin ISD
school with a project whether it was a
modernization or what we call targeted
projects where we're just updating right
a new roof, an HVAC project, but more
specifically is our security um items.
So, our secure entry vestibules, our
camera upgrades, um other life safety
things, those are something that we're
always going to do for Austin ISD. We're
It doesn't matter how long a student
needs to be there. Now, did we start
consolidations when we had our bond?
Absolutely not. And I think
Superintendent uh Sigura can speak to
that. I I think any school district
never wants to be in the situation that
we're facing right now. And um our 2022
bond was amazing, but we're we we still
have also a compliance piece with TEA.
Um there is a Texas school safety center
and it's something now that the Texas
Education Agency has recently um made
sure that we are compliant in many
school safety features including secure
entry vests. So that's something that we
just were committed to as a district and
we were in our bond when we passed it
and then the state kind of went
thereafter with a compliance piece. So,
I I don't know if you had anything to
add to that.
>> Well, so I I do want to add um you know,
just to be clear, as as Christine said,
if there's a student in our schools,
we're going to do everything we can to
make sure the AC is running and make
sure they're safe and and that requires
physical improvements. In 2019, 2020,
2021, when we were planning 2022 bond
program, we did not know the 23
legislature was not going to fund
schools. We did not know the 2025
legislature was going to kind of pass
off what they believed was an HB2, you
know, investment and really not really,
you know, move the needle significantly.
Um, you know, at the time we were
running into a huge, uh, deficit of
educators in the classroom. You know, we
had to make investments in our
educators, which really helped us move
the needle and recover from that period
of disruption. So, when it comes to
globally, could we have known that we
were going to be here? No. And that's
the honest truth. I I was in a similar I
was over operations at that time. I
never would have thought that we'd be at
this point. You would have felt as
though given the pressure in our state
and the lack of funding in public
education, we would have had some
relief. What's exacerbated this is the
um the disruptions at the federal level,
y'all. Like um title two, title three,
and title four funding is hitting us
hard. $10 million, you know, were frozen
in a really relatively short period of
time, which impacted a vets team that
supports stool language. It impacted a
hundred other people in Austin ISD.
These are people who have given their
career to supporting educators and all
of our students. And then overnight, I
have to manage that disruption. So, no,
I could not have anticipated this. That
being said, we take every dollar we're
spending very thoughtfully. We we we
work out deals with the city of Austin.
We construct quickly. we can construct
in a way that very few can and I hope
that you've seen that in 2017 and 2022
bond program and if there are other
questions around our ability to
construct compare us the city of I mean
compare us to other school districts is
what I'll say um I would say that we
actually do a very good job um but no we
wouldn't couldn't have known um and
certainly we recognize that um if we
could have known maybe would have made
different decisions but again uh we did
not think we would be here
>> and superintendent to add to that we
also have a community bond oversight
committee they meet monthly we talk
through every single project where it is
the status of that and the financials.
So that's something also that we have a
district communitydriven committee to
make sure that we are going through what
we said we did for the voters. And so
we'll be looking into what that looks
like in the future on how those bond
dollars could be reallocated in in
another way to follow the student which
is our goal.
Okay,
final question from comment cards. I'm
deeply concerned that pre-K students
seem to be have left out of the plan. As
we review the proposed plan, we see only
kindergarten and above students would be
guaranteed a spot at ODM. I urge AISD to
include preK students in the
consolidation plan to ensure that the
wall dual language model remains truly
comprehensive, that that families who
have invested in this program aren't
left without a clear path forward.
Yeah. Okay. Yeah, we can tag team. Yeah.
So, I just wanted to share that. Thank
you for urging. Thank you for the
comment cards. Um we are definitely
looking at prek, right? And that
continuation of programming. So, um you
you're likely to see uh a change right
in the next draft uh version that will
go out.
>> The only thing I would say is that the
prek students were included in the plan.
the um progression um into the program
it based on a transfer will be clarified
in our transfer policies. Um so my
objective is to be hyper clear out of
the 20 different scenarios that a
student could encounter or family could
encounter through this plan. We're going
to have a very clear um kind of response
on how that will impact transfers and
what we can do to ensure that that
disruption within for your family is
minimized to the best of our ability.
But the plan had always considered prek
for the wall to 12 to language program.
The transfers um and kind of our ability
to respond to those had not been um kind
of addressed in a in a direct way. So
we're making that adjustment.
>> Okay. So that concludes the comment
card. Before we get into the um
questions, I just want to um bring your
attention to kind of what's next. So
today is actually the first day that
Superintendent Sigura has been visiting
campuses. Y'all are number two. We were
at Martin this morning. Um, we also just
added a board workshop next Wednesday.
Um, so Monday there will be a um an
online meeting that will be
districtwide. There will be um a East
Austin focused meeting on Tuesday, the
workshop on Wednesday, and then um a
board voting meeting on Thursday. So
very busy, lots of um ways to catch us.
Um and then next Friday is when the
updated plan will come out. Um, and then
that next week on November 6 is when the
board will have an opportunity to
discuss that updated plan and still
moving towards that November 20th final
date. Um, so did you
I'm sorry.
Yeah. Well, is that
I think it's just that. Yes. Um, okay.
So, if y'all want to start, does anyone
have any questions? And I will say we
are recording this um so we can share it
with your community, anyone that's not
here in English and Spanish. So we will
be taking the mics to you. So please use
a mic. Um I saw you Yeah, I can do it.
Okay, I saw you first.
So I'll come I'll come to you and then
I'll kind of switch sides. So
>> hi. So uh you had mentioned the
registration time period. Um, it was my
understanding that this was going to be
delayed in this upcoming year so that we
could know the actual full plan and the
staffing before registration started. Is
that not going to is it still going to
kick off in November?
>> Yeah. Well, so our transfer um our
registration process starts in November.
Uh I do want to be really clear. We're
being very intentional given the fact
that these communities are going through
a a a different kind of out of an an
atypical experience with registration.
So when we release the plan, you will
see kind of our milestones to be
responsive to the registration process.
um because of every all the other
schools in the system at large uh we
have to go in and make sure that
whenever you uh go into the the system
if you were at Sunset Valley you know
you would have the zone school that you
could go to if you were a transfer into
Sunset Valley and I think it's 53% here
then you would have also the opportunity
to go to ODM and so that would be part
of it so I have to improve the system to
make sure that that's addressed u and so
those kind of adjustments will be
incorporated in
to your point, will the entire staffing
plan be complete before you register?
Uh, it depends on when you register. Um,
but we will protect the backside like we
will give you options and outs. Let's
say that you say Matias um based on the
plan I believe that we want to go to to
ODM and you based on the timeline we
have um for enrollment. you kind of
select at that point and then for
whatever reason you decide that's not
where you want to go like we would
support you kind of making that
adjustment because we know it's a it's a
change in what you were expecting. Uh so
there's some details to be to be worked
out with it. Um staffing plans in
general aren't really set until late
spring which is why it's so important
for me to get the principal set in
December. um because you start the
enrollment process, registration
process, but it doesn't actually end
until uh late into um February and
March. So, we you'll have that
opportunity. It it shouldn't be too much
of a delay.
Sorry if I lose my cool earlier.
Um so, I have a couple notes here. When
the first comment or round of comments
went out, I was more worried about
Coington, which well, she's gone now.
Uh, but I have two students here and I
understand that they might not continue
to go to the school, but I believe that
Sunset Valley is a great place for a
school. So, when the rubric which you
guys put together came out, Sunset
Valley scored the best out of all the
other elementary schools in the area and
the only one that it kind of like lost
points on was zone was too empty. Um,
it's unfortunate that now we're in a
situation where schools almost feel
pitted against each other, but Joslyn is
a uniquely bad in a uniquely bad
condition and in a uniquely bad spot. We
could go over there right now. It's
Sunrise is doing some some good stuff
and it might move, but the the homeless
community is going to be over there
seeing people defecating, exposing
themselves. Maybe they're just, you
know, using the restroom or whatever,
having mental episodes. It's caddy
corner away from a gas station which
sells liquor, has a big marijuana leaf
on it. Cork and brew is right there.
It's it's like a Fox News viewer dream
of what every Austin school looks like.
And it it looks like a jail. There's no
parking. It's on a small piece of
property. We have I'm on Sunset Valley
City Council. We have a police
department that is here for drop off,
for pickup. Officer Brownlow comes once
a week to talk. Oh, s sorry. Sergeant
Brownwell comes once a week to talk. We
have a beautiful campus. The uh Austin
uh sorry, Sunset Valley City Council
gives $20,000 a year to the PTA. We
support the school. We want them here.
When I was on the ODM or sorry, on the
call earlier this last week, I think it
was ODM parents didn't even want the
program moved over there. And so I just
I completely don't understand how you
take away this school from this
community. Sorry, I'm going long. Uh,
when it is successful and we want it and
we show it with our money and our like
voting everything else. I don't know. I
just that's me.
[Applause]
>> I just didn't know if you wanted to. I
mean, I I can respond that you if you'd
like. Uh so what I would say is that um
there are so many schools that are being
impacted that have very loving
communities. I just want to be really
really clear about that. There are lots
of people who love Joselyn just to be
honest with you. But so I I just you
know I want to just be really really
clear that that's not we recognize that
yes Sunset Valley um you know the city
of Sunset Valley supports this school
and we want that type of support for
every other school in the city of
Austin. not happening right now. I'm at
a point where I do not have the ability
to resource every school, not just
Sunset Valley necessarily, but 116 of
them. And so when you think about, you
know, where any one school is, they're
all going to have challenges. Right now,
what we know is that yes, there aren't
enough students that live in its
attendance boundary to ever fill it up.
That's just the honest truth, right? I
mean, that is that is just the truth
when you think about the program, right?
So you're what 24% emerging bilingual
and it's and it's been difficult, right?
And it's moving in the wrong direction.
So for sustainability purposes, you
know, to get to a 50-50 model, we have
to provide access. And so I I just want
you to know that it's it was never one
thing over the other. It was a
complement of things that ultimately
drove to this recommendation or this
plan. But though people there are
families that love ODM, they just may
not be able to show up because they're
working multiple jobs. They may not have
different access. I'm just I want to be
really I mean I'm just I know you want
Let me finish.
>> No, I I'm just telling you that every
school has a different experience, a
different community and I I just don't
want to disparage any other school and I
just and I just I feel as though this
plan we arrived at this draft plan. It
is a draft plan with a process that we
had built up over many months and had
been formed by other large efforts
including the long range plan, the
equity assessment, the bond program, all
these other things. So, it didn't just
like start from nowhere. Uh, and this is
where we are now. We're going to take
feedback. We're going to make
adjustments and we'll move forward. Um,
but I just I don't I don't want anybody
here to feel that I don't understand or
value the immense support that Sunset
Valley has from its community. That's
what makes this so frustrating and why
I'm so mad about it. I I'm just like the
fact that we're here is very um it's
just I just I can't I just hate that
we're here as a school system. So,
>> thank you. Thanks for being here. Um my
questions are kind of combos of these
two but as a community since we are
upset about moving why not reassure us
that we get if our administration wants
to go with us then say we're going to
offer it to them so that we can make the
decisions you know it would be great we
love our administration and we'll
support you if this is we don't want to
take over no one wants take over so if
we say if you can come to us and
reassure us and say parents we need your
support your administration gets to go
with you if they choose to. Now,
obviously, if they don't want to come,
we're going to but if they want to come
with us, why not reassure us?
>> So, I I want our families to know that
and your comments your questions is is a
great question and trust me, if I could
tell you right now, I would string to
the the as I possibly could that you
have that commitment from me to do that.
Um, I will tell you that I've met with
your principal, Principal Nato. I've met
with all the other principles who are
going through different changes. Um,
what you want is what I want. The
challenge is is there's not a board vote
yet and we still have feedback we're
getting from uh our community. So it it
it may change, right? And the one thing
I don't want to do is to create
disruption and confusion when we don't
have certainty in the plan. So we're in
this period of time. I have principles
right now, especially when it comes to
the turnaround plans where they're
engaging. They want to engage. They want
to start planning like, "Okay, how are
we going to support these students? How
are we going to plan transition into the
school year? What do you need from me?"
And I'm I'm hesitant to just like let
them go because if it isn't the vote,
right, and we don't actually get there,
then every pe lots of people are going
to be very frustrated. Um so we're in
this moment of time where um what you
want and what I believe this community
wants is what I would want to see
achieved. Also, we just are not quite
there yet with the board vote or with
where we are in the plan. But I want you
to know like that is one way that we can
ensure stability as best we can in these
transitions. I just can't share with you
kind of the conversations I've had with
Miss Nevada or the conversations I've
had with our trustees or just because
we're just not there yet. But I that's
that is precisely what we would prefer
to see happen. But again, each person
will get to make their own decision. Um
but I value our staff. I value our
principles. They're incredible. I hired
her. I mean, I want her to be with us.
There is no doubt. Um and so I I I want
you to know that we are thinking about
that. I just qu can't quite commit
because of where we are in the process.
>> Hi, thank you for being here and thank
you to the Sunset Valley community for
being really respectful and kind and
thoughtful and everything you guys have
been providing. Um, if the majority of
the highincome families from Sunset
Valley move to ODM, how will this impact
the critical title one funds and the
community services like dentists and
etc. that the community gets and needs.
So, title Yeah. So, um, so Title One
dollars, for those who who may not know,
um, they're dollars that are allocated
to the school district based on our
total number of students who are
identified as economically
disadvantaged. Right? So, we identify
them, we get information, and and what
I'll tell you is um, four or five years
ago, we were over 60% um, uh, 60% um,
economic disadvantaged. Um, as a city
has changed, we've gotten to 56%, 55%,
54% and we are desperately trying to
stay over 50%. I will tell you the
immigration uh laws changing um has
adversely impact us. Uh we're about
2,000 students down now down right now
for this school year because we have um
immigrant families who chose not to come
and we have immigrant families who chose
to leave. And so all of those families,
many of I won't say all them, many of
those families would have been in that
uh uh that kind of group of students who
are identified as economic disadvantaged
we have to get over 50%. So we are just
so if you have forms and people are
asking about these forms, that's what
they help us do. If we get over 50% then
we get our title one allocation and that
title one allocation gets distributed
based on our this is the district's
percent of emerging by I'm sorry um
students identified as economic
disadvantaged by campus. Two years ago
it was based on census track. So you had
schools that were in certain parts of
town that um had high transferin rates
that were actually not economically
disadvantaged from a majority of student
population but were in a census track
that was identified as um having uh a
high percent of families who were um
economically disadvantaged. So we've
taken that over and what we said is the
money will follow the students. So now
what we've done is said okay based on
student need you know any um uh student
population that exceeds 30% uh uh of the
student total student population that is
identified as economic disadvantages get
funds from AISD we then uh so moving to
ODM based on the numbers that we have we
will we will exceed that so I do expect
title one dollars to be allocated to ODM
um and so I think we'll be able to to
address that but we're the ones that own
the 30 to 40 the federal side is 30% %
we actually go north of that to like 38
40%. But we the AISD sets that the
federal law federal side sets the
minimum and then we can go above that.
That's how it works. Um I do feel
confident ODM will have title one
dollars. I also want to be really really
clear. It is highly likely with this
administration and the way that the U
Department of Education is going that
the title one funds will move towards
block grants. If you move towards block
grants, it's no longer necessarily based
on um the number of students that you're
serving, the types of student needs that
you have in your school district. It's
based on proportionality uh as an entire
state. So, there is going to be movement
in that realm regardless. So, it is
something that I'm desperately trying to
hang on to, but it is changing. The
changes at the federal level are
impactful, and that is one way that they
are going to be impacted moving forward.
Uh we do expect title two and title
three and title four dollars to go away
at the end of next year. That's already
been public and we do expect to be
tighter controls around title one
dollars. So my goal is to get all of our
schools to be at a place where we do not
have to rely on funds that we know will
be disrupted. Uh and the only ones that
we can really rely on are the um you
know the what the state gives us by way
of the basic student aotment. So so
that's kind of how we we're approaching
it. I hope that's helpful. Um, but we do
believe that we'll be able to have title
one dollars allocated. And then the
partnerships for wraparound services,
whether it's after school care or a
pantry, all those things, we can do that
independent of title one dollars. And we
do it now independent of title one
dollars.
>> Okay. Before we go to the next question,
I do want to clarify when uh he said uh
the administration, it's the federal
administration that manages the title.
>> Sorry, not sir. Thank you. Thank you for
being here, Superintendent Sigura and
officials and trustees. Thank you for
being here. I just wanted to follow up
on one of the first questions that you
addressed. There is a school that uh
will remain nameless that doesn't like
where their wallto-wall dual language
program is moving and as a way to hack
this system that you have that you have
laid out here. The rumor is that they
are going to transfer in the spring,
thereby becoming legacy students for the
next year and then taking away our
priority seats. I want to know is the
district aware of that and if not um can
you come up with some kind of mechanism
so that that doesn't happen and doesn't
basically screw us all.
>> Yeah. So um we we have we I will tell
you that I'm aware of a lot of the um
ideas that I will say that are out there
um with all movements. Uh I had not
necessarily heard the spring transfer
mainly because of how our transfer
policy works. Um once you're out too far
into the school year, transfers have to
go all the way to the board. Um there
isn't a formal process. They effectively
become a hardship um transfer. uh those
are few and far between. So there
wouldn't be the opportunity to do like a
mass transfer. Um all those would
actually effectively under current board
policy go to the board. Um my team
reviews them. I make a recommendation to
our trustees. We talk about an executive
session and then we come out and make a
vote. Uh I would tell you that anytime
that there is a desire to circumvent um
use the word hack. I don't know if I use
that word, but uh to to kind of maybe do
something that's not in alignment of
what we're trying to do or maybe out of
alignment of our values. Um you know, we
need to understand that and then figure
out like how can we address that? So, I
appreciate you sharing that with me. I
had not heard that. I do think the
current transfer process would limit
that in in many ways. But when it comes
to um ODM, what we talked about is
because that this is the school that
will receiving the program. Our
expectation and my expectation to the
team is that those seats are protected.
Um and then anybody that's comes from
another wall to wall language program
would be after that and then anybody
outside of those would be kind of next.
So I appreciate you sharing that. Um
thank you for for that input.
>> Thank you for being here today and thank
you to our trustees for being here
today. I have two somewhat unrelated
questions. Okay. My first question
should be a softball question. So the
consolidation plan says that and I have
a prek4 student. Okay.
>> Um so it says prek students will
continue to follow current policy.
Current policy for dual language
programs is that if you're enrolled in
the prek school, they will be given
automatic entrance to kindergarten with
this transfer to ODM.
>> I was unclear about what you said
earlier. Is my prek4 student
>> Yes. protected? Yes.
>> Yes. Okay. Yeah, and we're and that's
where it comes back to the scenarios.
There are lots to the gentleman's point,
there are lots of ideas and scenarios
that we're learning that people are
trying to navigate. So, we're going to
put extreme clarity and to your example,
we will provide a precise response and
it'll be yes.
>> Okay.
>> Softball question. Um the second one and
and forgive me on this verbiage if I
don't have it down correctly. Um, but
it's my understanding that Sunset Valley
doesn't have certain instructional
support and that Sunset Valley has
certain gaps as we hypothetically um
move to ODM as a community. How is the
district going to ensure that we're able
to secure some of these instructional
supports that we currently don't have? I
think that um we would all agree that
Principal Navaro is an excellent
principal and that we want to set up
[Applause]
and that we support her. Um, if if this
move, if this vote happens, we support
her and want her to have a strong
foundation in our community to have a
strong foundation. So, is this something
that the district has contemplated
um districtwide, but specifically for
>> So, a couple things. Um, when I first
came on board, it was clear there's
misalignment within academics and school
leadership. uh what was happening was
there was uh in some cases good things
coming out of academics but they weren't
making their way into the classroom. Uh
and some of that was because we didn't
provide the professional development or
support to our our principles, right?
They're the academic leaders in our
schools. Uh at the same time, you know,
we had a real gap. We didn't have
aligned curriculum. We had, you know,
some students experiencing something in
one part of Austin. They would rent
would may rise by 20%. they go to a
different school, a different scope and
sequence and and they were just not
supported in the way that we should
have. So over the last two and a half
years with Dr. Maxwell coming on board,
many of youall may not know Dr. Maxwell.
She is our assistant superintendent of
K12 academics. She has completely redone
um all of our supports within academics
and I would argue we probably have one
of the strongest academic teams that
we've had in a very long time. Avette is
on her team. She may probably echo what
I just said about Dr. Maxwell. She's in
our schools. She's probably more visible
than any assistant superintendent of
academics like that it's ever been in
Austin ISD. Uh if there are gaps, we
need to know about them. Your principal
and uh and a vet will be the ones kind
of identifying where they are. And then
in the transition plan, which we're
going to be very precise with this is
what I would expect to occur and if
that's something that's a gap that has
to be filled, then we're going to fill
it. Um I can't speak to specifically
what those gaps are. I would need to
understand that from your principal uh
and others, but yeah, I mean that's
that's the goal here. I mean, right now
we are fragmented. I mean, we we we've
made some significant moves over the
last two years, but there's still a ways
to go. So, yeah, and and if you see
something, send us a card, say, "Hey,
this is what I heard." Um, and maybe
it's been addressed, maybe it's not
addressed, maybe it will be addressed,
but it's important that we know.
Seriously, it's very helpful. Christ Oh,
sorry.
>> Thank you for being here. Um, I'm
incredibly grateful for your team and
our board of trustees for creating these
opportunities and all of the community
engagement that you've done. Um, so,
thank you. I just want to understand a
little bit about the turnaround plan
because ODM will have one of those in
place or No,
>> no, no. So, a turnaround plan. Um, so I
I didn't mean to stop you. Did you do
you want to finish the question? Was
that question? I guess I just want to
understand how
you plan to elevate the um academic
record that ODM currently has because
we're going to be coming in with a diff,
you know, a different scenario and I
just want to continue the academic kind
of excellence that we are already
achieving here at Sunset Valley.
>> Yes. So, so there are two things I would
say to that. The first is um do not base
every school on their letter grade. Um,
we have incredible schools doing
incredible things uh that have, you
know, maybe they don't have an A or a B,
but they have a line out the door,
right, of people waiting to get in that
school. And there are people right now
like advocating just as much as you are
um to protect their school even though
it has that rating. Um, so for us, you
know, we want to have strong
neighborhood schools. We want students
who are just great humans, that advocate
for themselves, that view being
bilingual as a superpower, that feel
comfortable, you know, talking to people
who don't look like them. Like that's
what we want in Austin ISD. Now what I
would say is um you know if because the
schools have letter grades that they
have it's because the system has failed
like we as AISD have have produce the
outcomes that we see right that that's
how it's designed and so we are
desperately trying to to take ownership
of it do it our way and our way requires
time we can do it there's other school
districts around the state of Texas
who've decided to do it a different way
right we're protecting librarians we're
protecting planning time we're
protecting our curriculum People don't
realize there are school districts right
now selecting curriculum that I know for
a fact would not work with this
community, but they're doing it because
they can save $8 million. And so, um,
when it comes to turnaround plans, two
UA and three UA schools are the ones
that get turnaround plans. A UA for is
is unacceptable.
That's just I didn't do that. That's
what the agency did. So, UA um and it
and it's a combination of things. It can
be two Fs. That could be two UAS. It
could be three D's and one F. That would
be two UAS. Once you have two UAS, you
are required to develop a turnaround
plan. You then typically would have one
year to plan and develop it and then you
would have the third and fourth year um
to implement and then ultimately get out
of that accountability um position by
year five. Because of the way 23, 24,
and 25 came out, 24 accountability and
25 accountability are on the same
timeline, which makes it a little more
challenging for us. And so we have three
UAS that would include other schools
many of them that you know and so for
there we have to have a different
approach uh because we cannot get to a
place where we ever get that fourth or
fifth. What I'll tell you is not that I
am I'm I don't necessarily believe in
the accountability system in the way
that others do but I want to be honest
like I want our students to be
successful in any summit of assessment
they get period right but to do it our
way. Um in 2023 we had 30 Fs in 24 we
had 29 and in 25 we have 23. We have I
mean our system is responding in a
positive way. Um ODM does not have a
turnaround plan right? So they they did
have a little bit of a drop um um
academically and there's a variety of
reasons why they may occur. Um but we
are providing the supports uh there you
all are going to help contribute to that
assuming that this plan moves forward.
So I want you to know like that's kind
of what you see from time to time. We
are modeling that there is no turnaround
in place at this point and I don't
expect that there ever will be one at
ODM. Um just to be really really clear.
So is that helpful?
>> Okay. Thank you.
>> I just do want to note that we're
bumping up against time but we started
like five minutes late so I am gonna
like go over a little bit because I've
committed to at least three people.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Whatever is needed.
Oak Hill
Sunset Valley.
Valley.
and Joselyn
overflowing.
And real quick in English, y'all, um I
think we've done a lot of work within
the Sunset Valley community recently to
reach out to and understand the very
diverse needs and perspectives of our
emerging bilingual families. Some of us
come from beyond the wide oakill. Some
of us walk to school and are not
comfortable or do not feel safe using
AISD transportation even if provided. So
even if all of us would love to move as
a community to ODM with our beloved
principal and our teachers and staff,
not everyone will be able to make that
transition. So I'm asking for as much
information and clarity on the plan for
Joselyn so that families can have that
information, make informed choices
upfront, which school or educational
model will be a better fit. What's the
difference between dual language and
immersion specifically? and then we can
really have a stronger dual language
community across Southwest Austin
including whether it's in this building
or Joselyn or ODM or beyond.
>> Yeah, great question. Uh so the first
thing I would say is um we have dual
language programs in 50
57 of our elementary schools. Um so this
is a wallto-wall dual language program
but there are school we only have 78
elementary schools. So 58 of them have
dual language programs. And so by board
policy, if there are over 18 students
who are emergent bilingual um within a
school, then we will begin to offer
that. And we have done that. We
committed to it. There are school
districts around the state of Texas in
central Texas that have moved away from
dual language. We are desperately trying
to find the resources to fully fund it.
So that's just who we are. So that being
said, we will have and there will
continue to be lots of opportunities for
dual linguage program in Austin ISD.
Again, they're all around South Austin.
Now, we understand that Sensitive Valley
is unique and that it's a wallto-wall
dual language program. Uh and and we
certainly understand how unique that is
and how beautiful it is and we want to
support it. There are lots of, you know,
there could have been ideas about going
away from it and that was never part of
the conversation. Uh we just want to
make sure that it's vibrant for decades
to come. Uh that is really our our our
core um goal here. What I don't want to
do is to get to a point where the number
of emerging bilingual students gets down
to like 10% 9% and then all of a sudden
we're in conflict with board policy
because I want y'all to know that there
are laws that have been passed the state
legislature that require every educator
to be certified. Now, it's going to be
kind of a ramp up, but I think it's K
through three the first couple years.
And so what's going to happen is if we
have a dual language certified teacher
and they're not in a school in a in a
classroom setting serving dual uh
emerging bilingual students then I'm
going to have to pull them right because
I cannot by law I have to make sure that
we have a certified teacher in every
classroom in Austin I we have 5 over
5,000 classrooms and so this is a when
we talk about urgency that is something
we haven't run into but it's coming the
law has already changed the the
certifications um are limited. We're
right now frantically f trying to find,
you know, those educators to to serve
our students, and it's only going to add
pressure to it. Um, so, so that's
something that we don't often talk
about, but it's real. It's happening.
And I do not want to be in a position
where I have to pull programming because
I don't have educators. I would prefer
to stabilize the programming to ensure
that I have adequate educators. And
where it doesn't need to be in Austin
ISTD because the students aren't there,
our trustees support the
administration's work in like
acknowledging that it probably shouldn't
be here. it needs to be where our
emerging bilingual students are and then
wherever we can provide that opportunity
provide other families that support as
well. When it comes to transportation,
we transport over 20,000 students every
day. And so I would really want to
understand why families are not taking
advantage of that. Um, you know, we
certainly understand that there are
different means that families have and
different, you know, opportunities to
access schools, but we we transport
student, we're bigger than CAT Metro. I
mean, we we transport kids all day,
every day to provide access. If there's
something that you're seeing that you
believe will be helpful to making our
families more comfortable, you got to
let us know because I I'm not aware of
what we can do, but I can tell you I
will explore it. We're committed to
exploring it. Um, so I just want to
share with you those two points. Um, and
uh, and as we think about overflow. I
don't want anybody to think that we
think JSON is overflow. What we're
trying to do is to create a complement
of opportunities in South Austin, right?
Maintain a wall to wall dangage program
that'll be vibrant. to create an
immersion program that also includes
Mandarin to provide a south option to
the north option at the same time
provide dual language programming
elsewhere in South Austin. It's it's
everywhere. I mean, when you look at the
schools that have it, there are many
many schools that have it to give access
to our families. And if I do it that way
and go unzoned, we can keep more schools
open. If I don't do it that way, then
we're going to ultimately have to close
more schools. So, so that's kind of the
balance and why this is one like
multi-layered effort.
>> Yeah. So she can she Yeah, I know enough
to be like she knows response.
>> That is a great question and there'll
also be more clarification on that right
in the in the new draft that comes out.
So dual language programming really is
looking at our native English speakers
and our native speakers of a partner
language, right? So the partner language
would be Mandarin, Spanish, Vietnamese.
We've got all three of those dual
language programs in Austin ISD. That's
pretty impressive. Um so it really is
looking at biiteracy right students are
learning content in both languages and
our emergent bilingual students have the
opportunity to learn language and
content together right so it's not a
separate class or or you know a separate
period they're learning it together in
an immersion program um it follows a
similar kind of design but it really is
primarily for our families and students
that are native English speakers so it's
that Spanish immersion where they're not
necessarily surrounded by peers that
maybe speak the partner language. Um,
but that's also a false assumption
because our families are very unique,
right? And there could be partner
language speaking in the household. But
primarily these are students that are
native English speakers, highly
proficient in English, and families who
value language learning, right? And
rather than wait until middle school
when you can take your Spanish one,
Spanish 2, those classes, Mandarin one,
Vanderin 2, you're also learning at
elementary, right, content in language.
So the main difference is it's really
focused, right, in supporting the the
native English speaker um in and fully
immersed in another language.
>> It this the design is very similar. So
there is uh still instruction right in
English in the target language. Um but
again the design is similar to what it
looks like in a dual language program
the students participating in an
immersion program are are non-emergent
bilingual students.
>> And so just to be whenever we place
whenever we think about location of
emergent bilingual or wall- to-all dual
language we wanted to also make sure
that there was enough students to
support the dual language programs that
were already in place. Um, so you'll
you'll notice that um that uh when it's
when this plan ultimately if it does get
supported and we actually see it come to
fruition, um we do not expect to take
away any dual language um offerings,
right? That could easily happen if you
go place a program and then all of a
sudden all the dual language emerging
bilingual students go to that program,
you create pressure elsewhere. Like we
made it a point to place these programs
at a place in in a part of town where we
knew that we would have stability long
term. That was helpful.
>> Hi. Um, first I just want to say I do
not envy your job right now at all. So,
um you're in a really hard position and
thank you for all the thought you've
given to this um whole process
>> when I think you know I can speak for
myself and I've talked to a number of
Sunset Valley families who were frankly
shocked right when we saw that the
school would be closing and um a lot of
my questions have been addressed. one of
them that I just like I was confused
about
the role that safety played in the
conversation and frankly after hearing
some comments here tonight I am like
flumxed I am more confused than I was
when I came in so a couple of things
that I've heard here tonight one of the
things that I heard you say was that if
there's even one student in a building
we will do everything we can to keep
that student safe and I appreciate that
And as a parent, the most basic thing I
want for my ch my children is to feel
safe at school. And I think that many
other parents would probably echo that.
Um, I'm not disparaging Jocelyn. I'm
sure they have an incredible cultural
community. I'm sure they the education
that happens there is wonderful. But
facts we can't get away from are there
are needles at times on the playground.
If you spend any time looking at
neighborhood forums, the amount of
public indecency that happens in that
area is significant. And it's not just
going to the bathroom kind of stuff.
It's sexual in nature. Police get
called. They don't always respond. Um or
they don't respond quickly. A um APD is
overburdened. We also know that's a
problem. There are tons of policy
problems right now. And so I guess my
question is we have this school where
the police station is.3 miles away, two
and a half blocks, a six-minute walk, a
two-minute drive, maybe three minutes
with traffic. And it's also a fact I
heard you say that we don't have enough
students who are zoned in this area to
fill this school.
What I'm really confused about is if
Jocelyn is going to become a nonzoneed
school and it is factually a less safe
area with a building that AISD says is
not up to the same building standard as
this building, then why wouldn't that
nonzone school be put here where it's
much much safer? So, I would like to
understand the safety component of this
decision. Um, even if our wallto-wall
dual language program as we know it
moves to ODM, why would we not have the
program slated for Joselyn here? And um,
and that doesn't even touch on the
things like this school being essential
to the cultural fabric of Sunset Valley
and Sunset Valley having shown up as a
significant partner in ways even beyond
funding. Um, so that's my first
question, which is probably a lot to
unpack. But the second part of my
question is if this school does close,
what happens to the building? What
happens to the land? And is it at risk
of becoming a giant parking lot and
basically an extension of the concrete
that we see next door?
[Applause]
Um, so I will start with the second
question first just because uh, no,
we're our we're our goal is not to add
more parking anywhere in Austin. I mean,
honestly, in fact, I'm trying to get rid
of parking at Burger uh, if I can. Um,
you know, the so that's not the case.
Um, regarding what it looks like, um, we
have a process that we'll go through.
you heard I'm not sure I think earlier I
was talking about how peas ultimately
became a early childhood center or that
we've we've done different things unique
to the community based on the needs but
also balancing kind of the needs of the
district and there are many needs so
there's no desire to turn it into
anything other than what the community
and AIC can agree to that makes sense
like I've had examples where we've had
these conversations and someone says
Matias just turn it into like a dog park
I mean I would hope our community
understands that's not something that I
would be ever to take to I would never
take that to our trustees, right? But I
do want to activate spaces. I want to
make sure that we recognize that there's
a history, there's a vibrancy associated
with this location. Um I hope that
you've seen us at least since I've come
on board to be really thoughtful about
what that looks like. Um so I can't tell
you what it will what it be will be or
not be because that's going to require
all of us like having that conversation
and ultimately our board of trustees
weighing in. So that's that's the
process we would go through and we do
have a precedent for that and a process
for it. Um, regarding safety,
you know, this is this is one that that
is difficult because, you know, our
number priority is safety, but we exist
to educate. Um, there are lots of
schools in Austin ISD that anybody could
argue was less safe, more safe. You
know, it is a very slippery slope. I
mean, I just want to be I Sarah, I I
just I I get that. I'm just telling you
that when you look at different data
sets that we have in general, um, you
can anybody can compare any two schools.
Uh that being said, you know, we talk
about um you know, all the things that
played into it wasn't just safety. It
wasn't just any one of these things. Um
it just it just wasn't. Um you know, I'm
certainly aware of the physical
improvements at JSON just the way I'm
aware of the improvements that have been
here. I mean, I understand those things.
Um so I I just don't want I would argue
that because I speak with principal
Chowin all the time. I know that
community very well is also uh and they
will tell me that they they themselves
feel that is safe. Now what people
outside that put pressure onto that area
that is a different thing but talk to
the principal I mean principal Navaro
she knows Nato she knows principal
Chowin there are community members there
that are advocating for that school and
they safety doesn't they understand that
there are things around them there are
things all over the city that are
outside of our ability to control um so
I just want you to know it never came
down to a single thing um but I I do
want to acknowledge that uh if you want
if I need to produce more clarity into
um like how any one of these elements
was addressed when it came to a specific
um school. Um we'll attempt to do that
in our response, but I will tell you
that as you expand attendance boundaries
to add more livein students or you do
any adjustment, you begin to get to
other schools and then all of a sudden
you could have boundaries that are
wholly within other schools and you
could walk right past your school and
not have to be able to go there. So we
wanted to really understand the
feathering effect that would occur. I
mean, honestly, because of where we are
in the boundary to the north with Ben
White and the river, there's just not a
lot when it comes to expansion. Um, you
know, and and so there are a lot of
things that came into it. If I need to
add clarity in the plan, I will do that.
Uh, but I just want to be clear. It
didn't come down to any specific thing.
It was just a regional approach. Uh, and
this is where we arrived in the draft
plan.
>> Okay. Um, I know that there are a lot of
more questions and we are unfortunately
um over time. So, I do want to encourage
everyone to um submit a comment card if
you haven't already. Uh we are looking
at every single one of those and are
trying to incorporate um any feasible
ideas into the next proposal. Um and
that will be open through October 28th.
Um so, I don't know if you want to close
with anything.
>> I just want to say um thank you. Thank
you. Thank you. I very much appreciate
how you have approached this part of the
process. Uh it's not lost on me. I mean,
I'm from South Austin. and I'm born and
raised down the road. I love y'all's
approach. Thank you. This is hard for
you all. Um it's it it it is hard for
staff also. There are lots of people in
our system that also have kids in these
schools. Um so we appreciate you. Thank
you. We're making adjustments. We're
making refinements. And just thank you
for your time. Thank you for showing up.